weil ich einfach noch nicht lange
tomatenmark tomatenmark diese geräte
sind ganz ganz dicke leute was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut heute
haben wir was ganz spezielles vor das
video besteht zum großen teil aus der
block perspektive nach sehr langer zeit
mal wieder aber auch gleich wenn es dann
zum kochen geht ausleihen perspektive
also mit dingen ist hier juri und so auf
jeden fall habe ich mir für heute
überlegt wir machen mal wieder fit
challenges mit tik tok allerdings mit
werden da jeden tag so viele essensreste
also wirklich krank geniale essens
sachen vorgeschlagen und ich habe mir
gedacht lässt du doch einfach mal ein
tag diese tik tok for you page oder wie
der schweiz oder diese tik tok seite
irgendwie dein essen bestimmen sozusagen
also wir suchen uns immer zufällig
irgendwann wieder raus und kochen das
danach also frühstück mittagessen
abendessen das wird auf jeden fall
richtig bock wir fangen mit frühstück an
und ich würde sagen ich gebe einfach
break für sein unternehmen direkt irgend
eins davon ist ja halten oder wie macht
das jetzt am besten also das halt so
sozusagen zufällig ist okay dass sie
doch noch einer guten perspektive aus
wir gehen jetzt hier einfach mal auf tik
tok
das hier ist mein schönes irgendwie
immer noch allerdings glaubt alex ich
weiß ich warum das so lange dauert hier
oben steht zwar alex wie drüber was ist
denn davon jetzt mein richtiger
benutzername auf jeden fall könnt ihr
mir super gerne folgen fast 200.000 voll
aber schon leise und dann würde ich
sagen ich gebe jetzt einfach mal
breakfast ein
ihr seht also leute ich gucke jetzt euch
an ich solle einfach mal ein bisschen
runter das erste also eigentlich wollte
hat das erste was habe ich allerdings
schon mal gemacht und einem ticker live
acts video
deswegen wollen wir einfach mal ein
bisschen weiter runter und wählen hier
einfach mal aber ich glaube hier dieses
hier nämlich jetzt einfach mal
[Musik]
muss ich sagen sieht meist aus habe ich
so noch gar nicht getestet deswegen
machen wir das mal ich würde sagen wir
gehen jetzt erst mal einkaufen und dann
machen wir den breakfast burrito heck
let's go so weit
gerade hier ein bisschen am einkaufen
natürlich mit maske muss ja sein auch
mit einkaufswagen
das ist jetzt nämlich neuerdings hier in
köln weil schlicht wahrscheinlich aber
ich auch aber ist wahrscheinlich besser
so muss man ja ganz klar sagen wir
brauchen noch damit wir auch zu hause
immer schön desinfizieren können und
diese maske
jetzt passt wieder
[Musik]
so leute marie hat sich wieso ist sie
zum frühstück mit pizza das ist ja
absolut gleich die noch folgen wir haben
zwar fuhr und zweitens welche davon
gestern habe und nicht wegschmeißen
deutlich aber morgen schon ein bisschen
gearbeitet deswegen das jetzt wirklich
mein frühstück isst und 12 uhr hat ein
bisschen spät
alle mahlzeiten bisschen nach hinten
verschoben aber zu keiner zeit ist das
ganz normal
okay wir brauchen ich würde sagen zwei
reichen wir da eigentlich also wenn ich
wieder zu viele haben wenn man mich
eigentlich essen wenn ich direkt hinter
dann haben wir hier diese sortierten
avocado liga fußballer habe ich den rest
an der blockade und zu haben irgendwie
haben treten
das wird so lecker man also ein zum
frühstück ist das beste wir brauchen die
kurs das eigelb leute da zeige ich euch
ein ganz einfachen trick wie ihr das
idol bekommen können jetzt sehen wir
eine daher am liebsten was grüßt das ist
super super wichtig also ich bin schon
jemand nicht mag mutter deswegen
klatschen wir ordentlich futter
reinkommt einmal überall hin dass auch
nach venedig weil er jetzt schon ein
bisschen käse hier drüber und jetzt
kommt die worried obendrauf
so ist ein system angeschlossen so leute
jetzt habe ich gerade hier den korridor
drauf geklatscht jetzt kann es mal
wieder hier auf höhe
und jetzt können wir das hier perfekt
einfach umdrehen wie gesagt das ist
weniger als im video aber das ist extra
so ich habe auch irgendwie so dunklen
botanik vollkontakt naja hält sie hält
man die avocado abschneiden der rallye
mit einer avocado dann legt jedoch
einfach mal jetzt hier drauf also meine
avocado die ich gestern hat es auf jeden
fall deutlich besser aus aber es ist
okay jetzt habe ich gerade noch käse
drauf gemacht ja am becken avocado und
danach den brito teig und jetzt glaube
ich das mal zusammen sich zusammen kämen
ja aber schön zusammenrollen ist
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen heiß heute
der erste war irgendwie ein absoluter
mega sale ich habe den falschen teig
geholt
ja du hast abgeholt oder dieser hatte
kein worried das wird jetzt natürlich
trotzdem probiert und haben das feld
auseinander
das ist das zweite rein machen muss ich
mir und ich hasse 1
ich weiß nicht ob wir unbedingt nochmals
neue wollen sie wirklich gesund ich habe
ich das an
möglich wurde das jetzt in meine sachen
packen wir machen auf ein okay leute das
hier ist jetzt schon mal ein dritter der
deutlich besser geklappt ich habe jetzt
so langsam raus war jetzt auch extrem
schwierig das zu film weil wir haben
gerade morgens und ich hab keinen der es
wirklich mit filmen kann deswegen musste
ich selber film den habe ich jetzt aber
auch mit dem pfannenwender gewendet und
so zusammengerollt absolut professionell
aber leute das ist wirklich gutes
frühstück das kann ich euch lediglich
empfehlen so leute was gedacht wir haben
jetzt mittlerweile 14 uhr 40 und das
bedeutet zeit fürs mittagessen jetzt
machen wir natürlich keine 600 food &
dazu suchen wir uns erstmal also ich hab
jetzt gedacht wir geben einfach gut ein
und dem direkt das erste okay was kommt
und machen das nach müsste ja eigentlich
sie funktionieren also juli film mit
passt auf wir machen das jetzt einfach
mal so dass ihr das direkt auf kamera
sehen könnt ich gebe hier food 1
und ob und dann was ich mal kurz
anmerken muss was ist das da für ein
genie dem hintergrund ähnlich wie bei
der los soll ich auch nach machen mit
dingen mit dem gleichen lied nötig
heisst hinter alex alex folgen
[Musik]
danach konnte keine tasche gerieben
schon habt ihr eine käse so dass dann
etwas frischer kräuter wenn eure
comments fertig dann zeit darauf also
irgendwie mal hat mich das video ein
bisschen zum schmunzeln geworden muss
ich sagen da trotzdem sieht ganz lecker
aus deswegen würde ich sagen ich
probiere das marode okay leute wir haben
ja einmal alle zutaten die wir brauchen
milch mehl tomaten käse und butter und
jetzt komm ich selbst übrigens schon im
backofen drin hier unten
sie müssten auf löschung fertig sind
macht es einfach mal bei einer schnauze
dieses bisschen thematisiert die löffel
da da brauchen wir nicht als profi koch
hast du das einfach im blut fest wie
viele daneben augen mal spaß ja ja noch
weiter schnauze heilkunde
dann kommen auf jeden fall etwas käse
auch einfach weiterschlafen einfach so
rein und zu guter letzt einmal auf frei
nach schnauze bisherigen aussagen das
kann man den ganzen kladderadatsch
einfach bisschen bisschen verrühren
einmal frei nach schnauze auf mich sein
käse drin ich habe es noch mehr
käsemesser erzählt vielleicht auch
wieder recht ein bisschen käse könnte
noch dazu slowakische also es ist auf
jeden fall
nein
jetzt kommt auch hier doch ein bisschen
salz reihen wie im video auch nicht zu
viel und er hat andere kräuter
reingemacht
da haben wir doch auch so leute die
pommes sind fertig comedy sind doch
perfekt oder die habe ich einfach im
backofen gemacht wir haben ja keine
fritteuse doch an mir schon aber die
wollte ich jetzt nicht auf über nutzen
und es gab wieder alles eine fritteuse
und jetzt nehmen wir hier die leckeren
käse höhen superhero ab damit auf die
form ist was auf julian leist scholz
jetzt hier
diese gebäuden sind ganz ganz dicke
kommt auf okay leute mein team stelle
menü ist fertig also ich muss sagen an
sich sieht es ganz neues aus leider ich
dachte man kann das so aus ihm jetzt
hier
ich weiß halt noch nicht ob ich die käse
so sofern sollte manchmal eine gabel
was hat sogar zur jugend gut aus ok
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob mich ob
mich das überzeugt
also sind wir nicht an bord klettern
schöpfer habe ich nicht mal schön auch
mit den tomaten wirklich mit top
kombinationen engagieren die richtig gut
dass ich den mal ausprobieren gebrauchen
kost ist braucht jedoch dass es dann so
geil beste album change in übelster okay
ist das jetzt auf und dann sehen wir uns
wieder abend wieder weil da gibt's auch
noch was gutes geplant also ich weiß ich
noch nicht aber es wird bestimmt nice
deswegen bleibt dran und das spiel leute
was geht ab ich hoffe ihr seid noch da
der tag war bis jetzt auf jeden fall
wirklich anstrengen muss ich sagen ich
habe einiges gemacht und war so gut wie
gar nicht traurig war noch gar nicht
draußen was einen natürlich immer sehr
außer einkaufen halte was er natürlich
immer sehr mitnimmt muss ich sagen
deswegen nicht super gerne jetzt da ich
noch eine runde joggen würde
nachdem ich aber gegessen habt weil
hunger habe ich auch und ja ich bin echt
fertig kann mich gar nicht konzentrieren
was aufzunehmen wir machen es ist
einfach so leute ich würde sagen diesmal
mache ich so ich gebe wieder einfach gut
einnehmen aber nicht das erste sondern
irgend eins also ich mache einfach augen
zu uns herunter also augen zu machen
gefällt mir gerade noch ziemlich gut
schulkantine alter wenn ich die mit
unserer kantine vergleiche brutal
ich würde sagen kann ich ja nicht machen
ich habe ja keine schuljahr die niveaus
zwei einfach noch paar mal runter und
einfach vor allem das waren ja einfach
nur brück also das ist ja ein witz gegen
den rest nicht schon gemacht haben das
war einfach nur toastbrot mit
tomatensoße mit bisschen käse mit
bisschen tomaten drauf mit bisschen salz
wahrscheinlich oder pfeffer aber ich
habe das so noch nie gemacht deswegen
herzlich willkommen in der ketscher ich
habe mir das schon mal ein bisschen
prepaid also wir das im video irgendwie
mit alufolie gemacht dann habe ich jetzt
hier tomaten pasta sauce besorgt von
meiner lieblings makel
nein hinzu kommen diese formaten und
hielt auch käse auch von einer absoluten
lieblingsmarken ein dann haben wir hier
noch sei es dass es auch mal gut
ich glaube dir mit video noch irgend so
ein öl draufgemacht das weiß ich nicht
deshalb die kleider nicht da ich hoffe
ihr verzeiht mir das dann komplett die
soße erstmal hier drauf weil der boden
dann krieg ich mach das professionell
nicht zum ersten mal so verteilen wir
das ganze mal schnell das riecht doch
schon gut halte ich bin echt mal
gespannt ob ich das überzeugt weil man
muss sagen im vergleich mit anderen
sachen ist das jetzt nicht sonderlich
besonders wieso geht das denn jetzt
nämlich auch das hatte ich aber nie
ach die ist noch gar nicht ach so wie es
alle die es noch gar nicht offen
immerhin gold ich dachte da schon offen
das hat man von käse da ein gemischtes
putzen schießen these ist auf jeden fall
weiß mag ich deswegen weil ich dadurch
auch gerne drauf weist auf ein solch für
die reine mitmachen
warum sieht es nicht gut aus übrigens
noch nicht so begeistert
ich habe mich hier nur für die privat
menschen wie schnell wir wollten sicher
bestens wilk ich bin tomaten könig ohne
scheiß ich mag tomaten halt wirklich
ersten halben jahr vorher habe ich die
nicht gemacht und jetzt wichtig tomaten
haben könnte weil die kommentare so
tomaten schneiden oder nicht ich habe
überlegt noch ein bisschen avocado
aufzumachen aber lassen wir das also ich
muss sagen ich bin schon ein bisschen
zufrieden so halbwegs gut auch mal in
kopenhagen zungen und wir sehen uns
gleich wieder denn da jetzt richtig
lecker und ja da hat mich mit herzlicher
auswegen den formaten ich habe noch nie
in meinem leben zuvor tomaten
geschnitten ist ein wirklich so weil ich
einfach noch nicht lange tomatenmark
tomatenmark kleines wort leute
ministerrat aufgefallen ich habe es
vergessen zu salzen das machen wir
nochmal doch nach und ein bisschen
pfeffer kommt auch noch drauf so gut
fertig ist es was ich brauche
warum sie gerade aus oder was man halt
sagen muss das hätte ich ihnen ein
bisschen mehr in die ecken gekommen da
habe ich als profi kann nicht ganz
überlegt also muss ich mir merken fürs
nächste mal trotzdem ja genial also sehr
einfach man muss ja nicht sagen so
besonders sieht es nicht aus also wenn
mittag war es deutlich besser riecht
aber gut im video waren dann auch
zwiebeln drauf und auch noch gurke gurke
feiert gar nicht auf so was zwiebeln hat
jetzt auch nicht so toll collect fehlen
zwiebeln aber tatsächlich ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen so richtig feiern dies
nicht möchte auf jeden fall lecker und
erstes safe auf welchem recht großen
hunger aber danach mache ich mir
vielleicht noch mal die pommes 100 meter
wie soll ich noch mal ein ganz kurzes
update jetzt im nachhinein muss ich doch
sagen es ist schon ziemlich geil dass
ich habe jetzt das erste tor zu
vergessen also wirklich sehr sehr lecker
der einzige nachteil dadurch dass wir
hier diese tomatensoße dann die tomaten
drauf haben und so weiter
das hängt alles so ein bisschen trotzdem
extrem heiß
soviel dazu erstmal abonniert auf jeden
fall der kader ist hat unfassbar viel
spaß gemacht und das war vor allem super
abwechslungsreichen gerade in der
jetzigen zeit hat man ja perfekt zeit
für sowas auch wenn ich sonst immer
genug zeit haben muss ich auch sagen
aber wenn ihr sagt mach absolut auf
jeden fall noch im zweiten part lassen
den genauen nach oben da steckt mein
zweiter kanal auf alex leider gibt es
jeden tag ein video auf abdeckung
instagram genau und täter natürlich und
soja weishaupt rhein kanal abonnieren